salut aujourd'hui une vidéo un petit peu
spécial jeu toujours rêvé de commencer
une vidéo loser je vais vous donner
quelques informations rester bien
jusqu'au bout je suis persuadé qu'il ya
quelque chose qui peut vous concerner et
même quelque chose qui peut vous faire
halluciner
[Musique]
en ce moment avec la tournée c'est pas
évident évident de sortir des vidéos
j'en sors en moyenne deux par semaine je
suis pas persuadé d'arriver en sortir
une deuxième cette semaine
si c'est le cas m'en voulez pas ce sera
pour gagner en qualité comme d'habitude
durant toute cette période de spectacle
je ne vous donne pas d'heures et de
jours de sortie donc activer la cloche
pour être notifiée si vous êtes abonné
si vous n'êtes pas abonné abonnez vous
et je vous redonne pas toutes les dates
de spectacles vous avez un lien dans la
description sauf que la dernière sera un
art et ça ça risque d'être ou faux on se
verra à la fin du spectacle je vous
dirai tout ça une fois que vous serez là
bas là je suis chez moi pour seulement
12 heures le temps de faire quelques
papiers cette vidéo et je repars et je
reviens de landouge effet faire ça par
un photographe qui s'amusent depuis cinq
ans à prendre des photos qui ressemble à
des lettres donc vous devriez être
capable de lire quelque chose là j'avais
juste envie de vous le faire voir alors
cinq choses à vous dire
la quatrième est ouf premièrement je
vous ai demandé très récemment sur les
réseaux sociaux principalement sur
facebook et sur twitter si ça vous
intéressez qu'on fasse un live parce que
j'avais une idée de live vous avez
répondu oui en masse je flippe
clairement techniquement de comment ça
va se passer mais on va organiser ça je
vous donne rendez vous le 16 avril pour
le premier live sur cette chaîne alors
ce live aura un sens ça va être un jeu à
base d'énigmes et autre chose et c'est
une idée que j'avais depuis très
longtemps en vidéo
mais du coup ça avait pas tellement de
sens de le faire tout seul ou avec un
invité mais en fait avec vous c'est
juste génial donc rendez vous dimanche
16 à brick je vous laisse me proposait
une horaire dans les commentaires pour
voir un petit peu ce qui arrange tout le
monde deuxième chose où sont passés les
résultats de l'expérience mentale numéro
deux il arrive c'est extrêmement longs à
traiter je sais je voulais déjà dit dans
une vidéo
mais je veux pas vous balancer ça à
larache ou avec des chiffres à larache
s'apprend ouf de temps et avec les
autres projets à côté en ce moment j'ai
du mal à traiter ces données ça sortira
dans le mois d'avril et la date je vous
la donne et en vous disant quelles vont
être les vidéos que j'ai prévu pour ce
mois ci c'est la première fois que je
fais ça vous dire un peu les vidéos que
j'ai prévu pour le mois il va donc y
avoir les résultats de l'expérience
mentale numéro 2 tout un hack live sur
la mémoire via une question que ma pause
et guillaume à l'issue d'un spectacle
puisque à chaque fin de spectacle on se
rencontre on prend des photos on discute
et des fois vous me posez des questions
jeudi à temps je vais pas répondre à
cette question je veux en faire une
vidéo
et si la question était très pertinente
pour créer un automatisme mémorielle on
en reparle bientôt une vidéo sur une
boîte magique on va ouvrir ensemble il
ya quelqu'un du nom de xavier qui a
fabriqué une boîte spéciale pour moi
c'est cette boîte là il a passé 127
heures dessus il ya une
mais pour l'ouvrir et on va essayer de
les résoudre je referme story parce que
vous demandez parler dans les
commentaires je vous ai dit bah ouais ça
vous branche c'est que ça fait longtemps
et apparemment ça vous branche
donc je vais en refaire une le live
qu'on va faire le 16 un bout ce brain
comme j'en fais régulièrement sur la
chaîne sauf que là mon geste m'ont
invité c'est vous c'est une vidéo buzz
brain interactive pas en live mais
interactive 1a kleisch pour gagner un
jeu je vous dis pas encore quel jeu un
petit peu de suspense et une nouvelle
vidéo de mentalisme plus version non
verbale on va parler des mouvements du
regard avec ce qui a changé par rapport
à ça et qu'est-ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui
encore en déduire d'une manière
scientifique
ça nous fait déjà pas mal de choses
j'espère que ce programme doit vous
plaire quatrième point je vous avais dit
que c'était ouf
le quatrième point est ce que c'était
juste un truc plus ta clique pour
cliquer non il est où vous vous souvenez
que j'ai deux trophées des 100000 j'ai
reçu deux trophées pour les cent mille
et bien je vous faire gagner un des deux
trophées
voilà j'ai pris la décision de me
séparer d'un des deux trophées ça fait
un moment que je me demandais comment
j'ai trouvé l'idée et c'est chez l'un ou
l'une d'entre vous qui va aller
quatrième point bis avant le cinquième
point beaucoup de monde demander quand
est-ce que je serai à la vidéo city a
priori j'y suis samedi et dimanche ce
qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que j'y
suis ce samedi par rapport à ce qu'ils
m'ont envoyé j'ai du mal à avoir toutes
les infos donc voilà samedi en fin de
journée j'y serai ça c'est certain
et donc le cinquième et dernier point
c'est par rapport à mon livre qui va
sortir le 18 mai qui s'appelle votre
cerveau est extraordinaire j'ai toujours
lu j'ai validé tout ce qu'il y avait
dedans toutes les corrections été fait
évidemment j'avais une idée pour en
faire gagner un d'une manière originale
ça s'appelle votre cerveau est
extraordinaire parce que je voulais pas
appeler ça un truc de mentalisme vous
devenez mentalista vous connaissez déjà
mon point de vue sur ce genre de
définition mais je vous en parlerai plus
longuement dans une nouvelle vidéo
sûrement non répertorié un tout petit
peu avant qu'ils sortent et si vous
voulez faire les tarés et précommander
c'est dans la description
il ya déjà eu des précommandes je suis
choqué à chaque fois qu'une brique au
monde juge ok ça faisait depuis le 2
janvier que j'avais pas fais comme ça un
point avec vous j'espère que vous serez
au rendez vous pour le live
je vous ai donné le calendrier du mois
d'avril vous pouvez me dire aussi ce que
vous aimeriez avoir comme thème un petit
peu de vidéo pour le mois de mai il n'y
a jamais plus stimulant que d'écrire des
vidéos quand vous me donner des idées
j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo sera
vu par l'ensemble de la communauté parce
que là il y avait toutes les infos donc
n'oubliez pas admettre un like pour
qu'elles soient bien visibles dans les
suggestions de tout le monde et puis
abonnez-vous si c'est pas encore fait et
rendez vous très bientôt sûrement samedi
j'espère je fais tout pour tchao
[Musique]
et
m